y comenzamos directo a la sección en la
que en directo américa vamos con uno de
nuestros corresponsales en esta ocasión
iremos a lima donde está francisco
zacarías es que en perú la noticia es la
destitución del alcalde de lima jorge
muñoz el jurado nacional de elecciones
aprobó un pedido para sacarlo de su
cargo pues en 2019 mientras lideraba la
alcaldía también recibía un salario
estatal por estar en el directorio del
servicio de agua potable y
alcantarillado sedapal
francisco bienvenido aquí a france24
explíquenos realmente hay intereses
políticos en la institución como dice el
mismo muñoz o que hay detrás de este
caso
podemos comenzar diciendo que la ley
peruana es muy clara está completamente
prohibido que un funcionario del estado
ejerza dos cargos públicos y mucho menos
reciba doble remuneración pero algunos
expertos señalan que les resulta extraño
que jorge muñoz haya sido sancionado por
este caso y el jurado nacional de
elecciones no haya medido con la misma
vara a la actual vicepresidenta tiene
baluarte quien siendo una alta
funcionaria de la procuraduría civil
ella sin haber renunciado al cargo
postuló a la fórmula presidencial del
presidente pedro castillo y quebró la
ordenanza tal como está establecida y
para coincidencias jorge castillo es
destituido del puesto de alcalde de lima
precisamente después de unos días de
haber exigido la renuncia del presidente
pedro castillo francisco y explíquenos
políticamente cuáles son las
consecuencias para la capital y para
perú de que destituyan a jorge muñoz
bueno se comienza a tejer una sombra de
dudas y de incredulidad hacia las
autoridades peruanas jorge muñoz ha sido
muy enfático y él ha denunciado que el
jurado nacional de elecciones estaría
siendo tomado por vladimir cerrón quien
es líder del partido perú libre que
llevó a la presidencia pedro castillo y
tal como ha indicado muñoz él ha
denunciado que las elecciones
municipales y regionales que se deben
realizar en octubre próximo
corren el riesgo de ser completamente
independientes y el denuncia que en el
fondo se estaría tejiendo todo a una
organización para favorecer al partido
oficialista perú libre gracias francisco
por toda esta información y de perú
pasamos a las noticias deportivas